the whole idea of Federalism is so  important because it's the only way you  can have a country with a few hundred  million people living together with a  wide range of social economic political  viewpoints together in peace what's  right for people in California is  probably not right for people in South  Carolina and vice versa and when we see  things that come down from a  one-size-fits-all centralized solution I  don't think anyone really ever gets what  they want and that's why this kind of  movement I think is so important when  you reject a federal centralized  approach and you start taking your own  view locally or on a state level we see  how things can grow and that's exactly  what's happened now with 36 states to  find Washington DC on a plant and I  think we can replicate that on other  issues and learn that localism is really  the way forward for Liberty